the federal reserve has lost their minds
let's first start out the federal
reserve new world record over this week
congratulations great job great job
great job great job
new world record federal reserve balance
sheet hitting an all-time high we are
now at 8.449
trillion dollars
they can't stop printing jerome powell
and all of his buddies they literally
can't help themselves if i drew this
chart on a piece of paper
you would think i was drunk that's what
the chart looks like it is just up and
to the right and there is no stopping
them they have the ability to create
produce and distribute money and boy oh
boy is that what they are doing
8.449 trillion but 8.5 trillion dollars
remember if we go back to 2008 2009 the
federal reserve's balance sheet was 900
billion that means
that means you know what we're only 500
billion away from a 10 bagger the
federal reserve is going to have that 10
bagger
500 billion dollars away from a 900 or 9
trillion and when they hit 9 trillion
the federal reserve hit the 10 bagger
and i promise you if they hit it this
year we will throw a 10 bagger party for
the federal reserve they're going to
throw a party
they got tired of seeing everyone else
with their 10 baggers and we're like
let's get one of our own here trust me
the federal reserve there's recently
controversy that they're all day trading
as well as they're doing this so they
had to have an ethics review at the
maybe the central banker shouldn't be
yolo longing options
while they're literally printing to the
moon so when the federal reserve hits
the 10 bagger we will throw a party we
are only 500 billion dollars away my
guess is that they have a shot at
hitting it this year
new world record of the federal reserve
balance sheet if we go ahead and we look
at the total assets and the percent
change year over year starting in 2002
here is the crazy part
so first back in the early 2000s we were
definitely growing a little bit you know
you had five four two two two percent
but from 2007 to 2008
big boy number 150
growth in the federal reserve's total
assets uh between 2007 2008 global
financial crisis that's when we decided
damn we got a new tool in the toolbox
warm up the printers let's go baby 150
growth in 2008. now we went minus 0.2
percent 8
20 minus 6. then we oh 2013 38 put a big
boy number on the board 11 then we did a
little tapering we started to go down a
little bit but you know corona said let
me help you let me help you federal
reserve and when corona struck the
federal reserve said we know this
playbook we're ready to rock and roll 76
huge number in 2020 76
gain in the or percent change in the
federal reserve's assets in 2020 now
some people say ah 76 was only
about half of what we did in 2008
true but it was off a way bigger base so
on an aggregate basis we printed
hundreds of billions in 2008 we printed
trillions that trillionaire energy in
2020. so 76
growth in 2020 20 21 we still imagine
this we're having 14 15 percent growth
from 2020 which had 76 growth our
compound annual growth rate is off the
chain over the last couple of years in
the federal reserve balance sheet and so
if you look from 2002 to 2021 the
increase in billions of dollars is 7.7
billion
or i'm sorry a trillion 7.7 trillion on
the fed's balance sheet that is
1054 percent growth now what is
hysterical is that that one thousand
fifty four percent growth
is way more than gold's up it's way more
than bonds are up it's actually beaten
most asset classes so if you simply were
just a federal reserve if you could
invest in the federal reserve's balance
sheet you did pretty well over the last
20 years or so you absolutely killed it
and so when you start to think through
what the implications of this are well
why don't we look at the fed's balance
sheet versus the s p 500
and man does wall street absolutely love
the federal reserve charlie belillo i
believe is how you pronounce it he's
absolutely killing it all three of these
charts come from him if you don't follow
him on twitter highly suggest you go
follow charlie he's all on top of this
uh the fed's balance sheet
has exploded
1054 percent growth since 2002
and the s p 500 total return is 640
percent the fed is outperforming the
stock market
jerome powell is the best investor on
wall street now the s p 500 obviously
continues to just go up and grow like a
weed it continues to go towards the moon
and so what occurs here is the stock
market
is serving as an inflation hedge which
is pretty nuts when you think about it
and so the smp 500 unlikely to slow down
anytime soon because the fed's balance
sheet is unlikely to slow down any time
soon what do we think about the video
game numbers that the fed is putting up
the fed this is like impressive stuff
here what did we what was our guess a
few weeks ago like they would get to 10
trillion was that 9 trillion by the end
of the year 9 by the end of the year i
think i think they gotta make it 10 next
year they got a shot we we need one come
on listen biden this is me asking you
we're friends now come on help me help
you i need biden i need yelling and i
need jerome powell i need you guys to
work together get in a room i need a 500
billion dollar stimulus package that's
all i need if you hit me with the 500
billion dollar stimulus package
over 9 trillion will get the 10 bagger
without the party so listen if you want
me to throw a party that's what you got
to do i just need a 500 billion dollar
stimulus package but i mean it's pretty
crazy when you in all seriousness this
is nuts yeah it's nuts i mean if you
look at historically uh where we were at
10 20 years ago it was nowhere even
close to this obviously and it's
appreciated uh the balance sheet has
grown in tremendously uh in value since
then so it's crazy i mean last year was
obviously difficult and we've talked
about this a million times of kind of
what was necessary and what wasn't uh
and they're in a bad position but when
you have these different tools and
you're using them so aggressively uh
there's obviously kind of factors that
are gonna come off of it and other
assets are going to appreciate in value
uh and assets like bitcoin which we
obviously talk about a lot here uh have
benefited from that right because of the
inflation because of the loss of
purchasing powers and all these other
things so it's not really surprising to
be honest like given what's been
happening over the last year that it
inflated so much uh we saw all the
packages coming out we knew that this
was coming but when you zoom out for a
second and you look at it for the past
10 20 years in totality it's like absurd
there were uh points last year where i
said that they were going gonna print
five trillion and people were literally
like ready to like track me down and
murder me like they were not happy they
were like you're crazy stop
fear-mongering old stuff news flash they
printed five trillion dollars
and the reason is because that's the
only tools that they have when there is
an economic crisis they can only do two
things they can manipulate the interest
rates or they can print more money
that's it that is all that they can do
and what we saw was there was a
recession people freaked out and they
came in hot and heavy they took the 2007
2008 global financial crisis playbook
and they said why don't we add some
zeros to it and we are gonna drop
nuclear
monetary policy and fiscal policy bombs
on the market and investors loved it
they loved it they got so
rich off of this so guess what's going
to keep happening every time that
there's a market correction or some sort
of drawdown you're going to immediately
see them step in they are going to bring
the absolute heat with more monetary
policy and fiscal policy stimulus
because they know that it works it's
impossible you can't have the market go
down if every time the market starts to
look like it's going down they step in
and they manipulate the market higher
and that my friends is what is different
now we do not live in a market that
actually is representing what is going
on in the economy we live in a market
that represents the monetary and fiscal
policy decisions of our leadership hey
guys bang bang thanks so much for
watching the best business show today
and don't forget to check out our
partner sofi they make all this possible
they're a super app that lets you save
spend borrow earn and invest all from
one single platform and if you go there
today and you sign up for a sofi invest
account you can get between five dollars
and a thousand bucks for free from sofa
not everyone's obviously gonna get a
thousand dollars but everyone gets
something don't say that i never did
anything for you go check them out at
sofi.com
download the app and go ahead and open
an account
software.compomp and make sure you come
back and watch more of the best business
show we're going to build the biggest
business show in the world and we need
your help
[Music]